super fascinated by someone who's
telling us something that embarrasses
them yeah that's me true though that's
true the person who pretends to be too
perfect mmm who deflects it and says oh
there's nothing I'm not ashamed of
anything do we then naturally not like
that person we will love them if we see
why they say that instantly okay for
instance there's a movie do you know
Jerry Maguire okay so when we start out
Jerry Maguire we see Tom Cruise and he's
perfect he's in a suit he looks great
like conch who's always says he's an
agent and the very beginning of the
movie he's just as sexy as it can be but
he's at the bedside of one of his agent
players and he's an agent a sports agent
and he's he's a guy who can't connect
with anybody so we think well this guy's
an a-hole right we're not gonna like him
what happens in the first two minutes of
that movie when we have somebody like
that we want to punch him hard and make
him change and what happens is within
two minutes in that movie the little kid
that is the the son of the bore of the
man who's in the bed knows that Jerry
Maguire is a jerk who doesn't really
care about his dad and he says my dad's
gotta quit playing football he's had
concussions are you gonna help him quit
German girls hey your dad nothing could
make him quit super troopers nothing
then he answers his phone and the kid
says to him hey you know what eff you
and when he sees that it's like a slug
to the heart and the next thing we see
him do is I got home that night and I
realized my life is a sham all I'm doing
here is for nothing it's just for money
I've got to change and he writes this
thing called a mission statement and now
we're with him because this is a guy who
has been enable but now he's seen it
he's confessed it to us on the screen
and he wants to change that's why we
follow him so you can take someone who's
a complete jerk and you can make us love
him if you show this often through
confessional what his problem is and
that he's trying to change that's how
you make an unsympathetic character
sympathetic so many writers get this
note back from the producer he was not
sympathetic that's how you make
you show us his wound quickly another
quick example if you don't mind do you
know the movie super bad okay Jonah Hill
fat boy in it very unsympathetic treats
girls like meat then he confesses to his
friend in the cafeteria that when he was
a little kid he drew pictures of penises
and he was horribly embarrassed when
these pictures came out and he also some
confesses to the girl that he's not good
enough for her so even though this guy's
a jerk we're with him through the movie
because he's exposed his core wound and
we see he's trying to change bad movies
don't do that most movies are bad by the
way
70 to 80 percent of films that come out
do not have this compelling change it's
my job as a story doctor to try to put
that into story because that's what
responds why audiences respond that's
how they respond
you